How many stories really
in the world are there?
I think there's only
a handful of stories
as a general,
global, universal idea.
There's only a handful
because it's based on
experiences that are shared.
But then you get specific
because there's
the mechanics
of how things play out
that's different.
Hello, everyone! My name's
Matthias Schweighöfer.
Hi, I'm Zack Snyder.
I am
Nosipho Dumisa-Ngoasheng.
-I'm Peter Thorwarth.
-My name's Adam Price.
-I'm Shinsuke Sato.
-I'm Deborah Feldman.
-I'm Álex Pina.
-Hi, I'm Harlan Coben.
The three act structures
is great
because you have a start,
you have a middle,
and you have an end.
Three act structure
is very important.
Personally, for me,
that's kind of what
I've gravitated towards
and always understood
really well.
I think it also gives you
great markers
for
is this still interesting
or have we gotten boring
and bland
and things seem the same.
I kind of think
that I end up with
a slight three
and a half-act,
or almost four-act
basic structure.
I don't like
any kind of structure,
at least consciously
thinking about it.
We very much concentrate on
the whole episode
and find our way
in a natural structure
for the episodes.
Back in the day, my mindset
was that I had to have
a three act structure.
So I was very intentional
on dividing it
into three acts.
But the more I wrote,
the less I worried
about the structure.
The key to any protagonist
is they have to be real.
Has to be that character,
that when
you’re sitting at a bar,
you kind of wanna overhear
the conversation a little.
He must have a secret
and he has to have something
that is really touching.
In the end,
writing is a lot like
designing characters.
We are like psychologists.
My favourite stuff
to work on
is always why this character
is like a great hacker,
or why this character
is a great get-away driver.
The perspective
we have on a character
at the opening of a film,
and then who they are
at the end of the film,
and the journey
that they go on
to become,
hopefully, a hero,
or, at least,
a realised character
with hopes
and dreams and aspirations
and ability to love or hate
or whatever it is.
What you learn
in the first third
of Unorthodox
is an internal process
of questioning and doubting
that occurs in the mind
of the protagonist.
You want a protagonist
to have some problem.
I think
if you have a really, like,
perfect protagonist
who is perfect
and everyone likes
and has no flaws,
then there's
no real interesting story.
The best twists
come really from the heart.
You can have the most
expensive car in the world,
but if it doesn't have fuel,
it's not going any place.
This is true of all fiction
you've ever done,
is your hero travels
down the road of life
and you've got to put
speed bumps and pitfalls
and detours...
Being a writer
that works so much
in the 100% realistic genre,
it was a joy for me,
actually,
to go into
the supernatural genre
and all of a sudden,
discussing
can this character fly?
And it was amazing
to have
all these possibilities
on your table.
As a director,
there are layers of myself
that sometimes get added
to the character I create.
Sometimes,
my own characteristics
are aspects I end up adding
into the characters.
I think I went back
into the past
and I plucked episodes
from my life,
and I sorted them
chronologically
next to each other
in order to build
some kind of art.
I can't say
that the story isn't any way
based on my life.
Blood & Water
is not based on my life,
it is not based on any
one specific person's life.
What I'm trying to write
is a story
that will be universal.
And I've always found
the more specific the local,
the more universal
the appeal.
The themes are universal.
Love, redemption,
family, friendship,
relationships, hope.
Those things are universal.
I never believed
that Blood Red Sky was just
for, again, Germany,
so it should be
a German movie
and I had the idea:
what can be
more international
than
a trans-Atlantic flight?
It's about being specific
in your context,
but being global
in your universal idea
and story.
The story, itself,
is coming-of-age young girl
trying to find
her missing sister.
The idea of coming-of-age
and being in high school,
everyone
can understand that.
That's the globe part of it.
How will I write
so that people believe me?
And how will I write it
so that they understand me?
I think
it's a natural thing to feel
when you sit down
to write any book,
but especially a memoir.
I think, as a writer,
it's extremely important
to remind yourself,
at all times,
that you cannot write
for everyone,
you cannot write a story
for 190 countries.
Because, I think,
if you try to write
for everyone
you will end up writing
for no one.
I remember talking
to a Japanese reporter,
when the Japanese edition
of Unorthodox
was released as a book,
and she was telling me,
"Do you know that the story
of every
Japanese women's life
is unorthodox?"
She started to cry.
It's almost like
instead of this just being
my weird,
unusual life experience,
it's now part of
a universal spectrum
of the experiences of women.
There is no reason
for a woman
to experience shame
as a result of
this very common
lived bodied experience.
And that, to me,
is what I think
touched a nerve
for women
all over the world.
On a business level,
Alice in Borderland
was created
with the Japanese market
in mind.
But on a personal
and emotional level,
in became an opportunity
to share Japan's atmosphere
and its domestic feeling
and ambience.
I always hoped
an international audience
who didn't know Japan,
would get excited
or be deeply moved by it.
When we made the decision
that we do a whole film
about different nations,
and different people
from everywhere in Europe,
it became
like a really colourful film
and I love that
because language barriers,
fantastic
for a great sense of humour.
Close your eyes.
In the end, I always say
the writer is like a cook.
Each country
has its own recipe,
but from the same
universal ingredients.
It's okay for it to be bad.
Just write something.
I become
completely obsessed.
I think about it
night and day,
all of the time.
I wake up thinking about it,
I'm a distracted friend
or guest, you know,
if you're talking to--
my kids are used to it.
Like, all of a sudden,
I'll start giving
one of these
and the kids will go,
"Ah, Dad's gone off
to la-la land again."
I would rewrite
then throw it away
and rewrite
and throw it away
over and over,
to get to a point
of satisfaction.
Even the worst things,
things people would be like,
"This is a terrible idea."
It's fine,
'cause from a terrible idea,
something great
may come out.
When I have, like,
a little bit of a block,
I just write notes to myself
about what I want
to have happen in the scene,
and, like,
what needs to happen.
It can get you
jumpstarted a little bit.
I think work is a journey.
What you do
and what you learn.
Hence, you learn
from your mistakes.
You want to write something
you're passionate about,
you know?
Like, your story,
whatever it is,
whatever
keeps you up at night.
Writing is pretty arduous,
it requires discipline,
and I think that the passion
for the thing,
is great fuel
to allow you to do the work
of sitting and, you know,
putting pen to paper
or fingers to keyboard.
-Any questions?
-No.
Yes. Many. Hundreds.